hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast impulsivity and compulsivity
neural substrates and neuropsychiatric
implications I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
groups and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we have a few important
announcements before we be done this
presentation has been approved for a
category 1 continuing medical education
credit by Loma Linda University if you
are interested in obtaining CMI's after
attending this presentation please click
on the get your free CD c e credits
button in the bottom left corner of the
event screen this webcast is designed to
be interactive and we encourage you to
ask questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left the presentation window try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Trevor
Robbins Trevor Robbins was appointed in
1997 as the professor of cognitive
neuroscience at the University of
Cambridge
it was elected to the chair of
experimental psychology and head of
department at Cambridge from October
2002 he is also director of the
behavioral and clinical Neuroscience
Institute EC and I joining jointly
funded by the Medical Research Council
and the Wellcome Trust the mission of
the BNI is to interrelate basic and
clinical research into in psychiatry and
neurology for such conditions as
Parkinson's Huntington's and Alzheimer's
diseases frontal lobe injuries its
afrien iya depression drug addiction and
developmental syndromes such as
attention deficit hyperactivity disorder
Trevor is a fellow of the British
Psychological Society 1990 the academy
of medical sciences
mm and the Royal Society 2005 in 2014 he
was awarded a share of the Gretel in bed
brain prize he was also given the
American Psychological associations
distinguished contribution award in 2011
trevor has been president of the
european behavioral pharmacology society
1992 to 1994 and he won that society's
inaugural distinguished scientist award
in 2001 he was also president of the
British Association of
psychopharmacology from 1996 to 1997 he
has edited the journal
psychopharmacology since 1980 enjoying
the editorial board of science in
January 2003 he has been a member of the
Medical Research Council UK and shared
the neuroscience and mental health ward
from 1995 until 1999 he has been
included on a list of the 100 most cited
neuroscientists by isi has published
over 600 full papers in scientific
journals and has co-edited seven books I
will now turn it over to dr. Robbins for
his presentation hello so this is Trevor
Ben's University of Cambridge I would be
talking today about two concepts which I
think will be of great importance in
psychiatry in the future impulsivity and
compulsivity so let's see what we say
about impulsivity what do we mean by
this concept whether it is in the middle
and here's a definition actions which
are poorly conceived prematurely
expressed in other words behaviors which
are blurted out inappropriately too soon
I'm Julie risky inappropriate to the
situation and often result in
undesirable consequences now the
prototypical disorder in mental health
for impulsivity may be ADHD attention
deficit hyperactivity disorder but it
also includes substance abuse substance
abuse disorders drug addiction
mania and obviously personality
disorders such as antisocial behavior
now in Psychological terms that
definition are giving you covers quite a
lot of stuff so the type of mechanisms
we're discussing probably include motor
disinhibition you know the loss of
inhibition of your motor behaviors
intolerance to delays in patients
especially when you're waiting for
rewards and also a lack of consideration
or reflection when you're making
important decisions making the decision
too soon on the basis of not enough
information now is this a unitary thing
this impulsivity or can it be divided
into different types I think the latter
but we get to that later in the talk now
in terms of the brain impulsivity
probably involve some of the systems
that are depicted in this slide so on
the right bottom hand corner you can see
a diagram of the human reward system
with its frontal lobe components and
also the nucleus accumbens which is
there now depicted on the left-hand side
is this circuit schematically it's a hot
loop so it's shown in red it's a reward
circuit there are other parallel
circuits involving the frontal lobe but
we're interested in this one this
circuits very interesting in
anticipating rewards and this circuit
turns out to be pretty important for
impulsivity now these circuits are
modulated by neurotransmitters coming
from full brain and midbrain structures
they include the dopamine and serotonin
and knowing and they innervate different
levels of this loop and they're also
implicated in this behavior now we know
not about this system because originally
it was shown in animal work that this
system is involved probably in the
rewarding effects of drugs as well as
natural rewards such as food
and in particular the dopamine system
plays an important role in lists so for
example drugs such as amphetamine and
cocaine which work through the dopamine
system have their effects mediated in
this circuit now this workers trance
transferred or translated perfectly to
human work through the work of people
like Norval cow who's related to Leon
Trotsky and the Russian revolutionary
and what Nora found is that in chronic
drug abusers such as cocaine or
methamphetamine or alcohol abusers they
had reduced dopamine receptor binding in
the straiten in the human stratum and
you can see that in the diagram you can
see these levels of dopamine receptors
less than in normal subjects you see
they shine less brightly but one big
question to ask is whether this is a
cause or an effect of drug abuse so for
example you might think that this is
resulted through chronic years of drug
abuse but on the other hand it might
have been there before they abuse the
drugs and actually contributed to the
drug abuse so how do you work out the
calls our effect in this situation
there's a similar problem with behavior
so all of these studies have shown that
drug abusers are impulsive they show
this premature risky behavior whether
it's stimulant abusers opiate abusers
alcoholics or smokers nicotine abusers
but again there's an issue where they
like this before they took drugs or did
the drugs make them impulsive and impair
their decision-making it's just not so
clear so there are ways however of
addressing this tricky issue of causal
effect now humans when they measure
impulsivity use the so called Barratt
scale a lot
the Barratt impulsiveness scale and this
has questions in it like I don't pay
attention I'm self control
and they generally say no I changed jobs
they would say yes if they're impulsive
they're Restless at lectures impulsive
people so they jump around a lot their
motor disinhibited so this is how one
measures impulsivity in terms of
self-report introspection but there are
objective ways of measuring impulsivity
as well and fortunately we can use these
methods in rodents in rats as well as in
humans so these methods include measures
of patience when choosing rewards is
this called delayed gratification they
include a test called the stop signal
reaction time test which is a test of
motor inhibition and they include
attentional tests like the test you see
in the lower left hand panel here have a
rat in this case trying to detect brief
flashes of light which predict food and
the rat has to know spoke in these
apertures to receive the rewards of food
which are collected here and then he has
to turn around and attend to the next
cue now the interesting problem for the
rat is that it has to wait until the cue
comes on before he must respond and
there is a proportion of rats in the
list of population this is a Lister
hood it records zippy there's a
proportion of these rats who show very
high levels of impulsivity as you can
see here they're out with the normal
distribution they have a consistent
tendency to respond too soon now this
bleeds true when you do behavioral
genetics experiments and indeed Geoff
dally in our group has shown that the
genes involved are on chromosome 1 in
the rat now this is a very important
trait therefore this premature
responding and it's been shown by Jeff
dally and others that that's who showed
this high level of impulsivity when
subtle subsequently allowed to say
administer drugs such as cocaine or
nicotine intravenously and they do this
they choose to do this by hitting a
lever in this special box they hit that
lever there and it produces a shot of
cocaine in the vein now if this schedule
is allowed to develop so that the rats
can respond for long periods of the drug
intake of the drug may escalate and this
escalation occurs especially in high
impulsive rats for cocaine and also for
nicotine if they're allowed access to
nicotine and interestingly also for
sucrose rewards so these high impulsive
rats have a sensitive as it were to the
rewarding effects of drugs of abuse and
that's a very interesting observation
because it suggests to us that well
impulsivity is not necessarily just
caused by the drugs it occurs before
head-to may even contribute to the risky
behavior that is drug seeking now
additionally Jeff dally also found
intriguingly that in the ventral stratum
of these rats there was lower dopamine
receptor binding justice have been shown
here you see previously in humans and
this low receptor binding is also
correlated with the degree of
impulsivity as you see in this inset
here so these high positive rates have
low dopamine receptors just as human
drug abusers do and of course these
receptors are measured before the
animals took the drugs and so they were
part of the trait of impulsivity which
may contribute to drug abuse
now other studies have confirmed that
these receptors are reduced in the so
called shrill region of the nucleus
accumbens that's shown in the middle
panel at the top and also other
molecular changes in this region suggest
to us that actually the dopamine
transporter
produced as well and suggest that the
dysregulation of dopamine in this region
is contributing to the impulsive
behavior now the adjacent part of the
nucleus accumbens is called the core
region and the core region of the
nucleus accumbens also contributes to
this impulsivity so here you see the
reduction in gray matter in the nucleus
accumbens core in a section of the rat
brain measured with magnetic resonance
imaging and the graph below shows you
how well this correlates with the
tendency to impulsivity so the less the
gray matter the more the impulsivity now
that gray matter is probably so-called
medium spiny cells which use gather as a
transmitter and indeed as you see on the
right-hand panel these rats have less of
the enzyme which makes gaba GA d as it's
called and they also have left synaptic
proteins in this region intriguingly in
normal rats
if you impair gaba with anti sense if
you impair this enzyme as you see in
this bottom right-hand panel they show
increased impulsivity so what all this
adds up to is that the core region of
their nucleus accumbens is also
implicated in impulsivity and we've seen
this in another test where rats show
raised deep reward discounting if they
have lesions of the core region so in
this bottom right hand corner you see
the lesion of the nucleus accumbens here
and this leads to an increased tendency
to take the smaller of two rewards if
the smaller reward is presented ahead of
time before the large reward and you can
see this discounting function on the
left the steeper discounting here we go
of the high impulsive rats so they're
impulsive according to two criteria
premature responding
and impatience reward and it all
devolves on the nucleus accumbens so
this is our neural network of the
nucleus accumbens and you can see the
nucleus accumbens core and shell regions
both contribute to this behavior but
additionally there are top-down controls
on these structures as you see on the
right hand side and these are
particularly from the frontal lobes as
you see here controlling the output of
these structures as well on the
left-hand side you see not only the
dopamine system projecting to the
nucleus accumbens but also the serotonin
system and the noradrenaline system
which goes to the shell and they all
play a role in regulating impulsivity
and that's also seen from studies of
people with ADHD where drugs such as
Ritalin affecting dopamine and
noradrenalin are used to control
impulsive behaviors but what does all
this mean for drug abuse human drug
abuse is impulsive aterial II what we
call an endo phenotype is it call to the
condition and does it contribute
causally to the problems of drug addicts
well here's some translational
experiment where we use something very
similar to the rodent attentional tasks
for humans it's a full choice task the
human holds down a button and you can
see where that happens here and when the
visual stimulus occurs you release the
button and touch the screen and you get
a reward for that now the subjects are
encouraged to respond as quickly as
possible
so they do make mistakes and they do
release the button prematurely but guess
what
just as in rodents we find stimulant
abusers and recreational cannabis
abusers both make more premature
responses they both release the button
too soon so there you have a real
translation from the rodent to the human
it shows that that rodent work makes
some kind of sense
now another impulsivity task is the stop
task this is a fun task you're supposed
to respond as quick as you possibly can
either to the right or to the left
activated by a computer cue so these
come up very quickly but on some of the
trials are beep sounds and then that
beep sounds you mustn't respond you have
to cancel your response and it's
possible using this task to measure not
only how quick you can respond blue so
how quick you can stop you can inhibit a
response so imagine an ADHD child might
blurt out something you might want them
to stop that response and this is a kind
of loud measure of that and indeed with
ADHD these readout patients if they're
treated with ritalin which is the drug
treatment for ADHD it does improve their
stop signal reaction time here it's very
slow compared to controls is the
controls you can see it's slower and the
ritalin they're able to stop more easily
so they can control their impulsive
behaviors ok now this structure this
network is the network which controls
stopping it's a bit different from the
waiting circuit it's a stopping circuit
and it involves similarly structures in
the basal ganglia in the stratum but
they're in the caudate putamen and not
in the nucleus accumbens they're also
controlled by some top-down structures
from the frontal lobes notably the
inferior frontal cortex and they're also
modulated by these ascending chemical
systems dopamine serotonin and/or
adrenaline on the right on the left hand
side of the slide ok now intriguingly we
can use some of this evidence when
studying addiction so in the top left
hand of the slide you can see the
relationship between damage to this area
of the frontal cortex it's on the right
side and its inferior
and the stop simple reaction time look
at this amazing relationship the slow
you are the more damaged patients with
damage in their area have in that
particular zone so this zone is key for
stopping
intriguingly this zone is also
compromised in stimulant abusers and
Karin Asha has shown this in this study
of the stop signal reaction time task
where she showed that not only the
stimulant abusers show slow stop signal
reaction times compared to normal there
so do their siblings who don't take
drugs where the family members and
therefore genetically related so it's
intriguing that in both the siblings and
the stims abusers who are bad at
inhibiting their responding that this
correlates with their white matter as
measured by diffusion tensor imaging in
this region of the frontal lobes and you
can see this fantastic relationship
between the stop stop ability and the
loss of innervation of the frontal lobes
in the stimulant abusers and their
siblings note this very interesting
control group these are recreational
drug use as they take a lot of
stimulants such as cocaine but they
don't seem to develop addiction per se
they don't develop compulsive addiction
Lite behaviors and nor do they show this
impulsivity endo phenotype so it looks
like impulse ility may be linked to the
tendency to become stimulant dependent
or stimulant addicting now we've got a
similar story when we studied healthy
adolescents prospectively
this is another way to get a causal
effect so in this study in europe 2014
year-olds are recruited from schools
normal 14 year olds and given the whole
battery of test clinical tests
neuropsychology tests and brain
structure functional brain imaging the
whole lot and I'm going to show you a
snapshot of the data on the stoppe task
because he
sections of the brains this is a summary
of the of those networks which were
activated during successful stopping in
the ability to successfully inhibit a
response and you can see intriguingly
these frontal areas or widowed frontal
here and here right inferior frontal
that area I mentioned earlier basal
ganglia here this red areas and also
structures such as a supplementary motor
area which probably delivers the
inhibition of the response now as I said
here different networks associated with
different aspects of impulse control
but adolescents reporting drug use
that's alcohol nicotine or both of these
substances had reduced activity in these
lateral green areas intriguingly those
adolescents additionally reporting
illicit drug use had initially increased
activity in this right inferior frontal
area so the something abnormal going on
there and we know later on in the course
of drug abuse this area becomes
hyperactive less active so it may be
that they're trying to control their
drug taking but eventually can't do it
so here's two bits of evidence therefore
to show you that these relationships
between impulsivity and stimulant drug
addiction appear to be there but how
does this factor into compulsivity what
is compulsivity is it different from
impulsivity it's a very similar
definition but it is different we would
argue that its actions which persist in
appropriate to the situation they per
separate they continue they have no
obvious relationship however to
goal-directed behavior and they often
result again in bad consequences
now these impulsivity could be due to
low to disinhibition you get these
syndromes called stereotypy for example
in stimulant abuse
so perform the same actions over and
over again there could be enhanced habit
learning this is one of our favorite
hypotheses as behavior becomes
multimatic we think that the the purpose
of a behavior is neglected and the
behavior becomes an end unto itself
persistent behavior is shown when
extinction is studied when the reward is
taken away or the contingencies change
and also just when you think in a very
rigid way when you have cognitive
rigidity now what do these traits
contribute substance abuse is defined
nowadays almost by the new dsm-5
diagnostic system as compulsive drug use
eating disorders can be compulsive will
know about gambling and compulsive
gambling and prototypically OCD
obsessive compulsive disorder is the
ultimate compulsive behavior now is
there something called compulsivity
which covers all of these conditions is
there something in common to them now
let's consider this first of all this
brilliant quote from the great clinician
choco bran is a great addiction
clinician I read it to you at some point
after continued repetition of voluntary
drug taking the drug user loses the
voluntary ability to control issues at
that point the drug user becomes rule
where we go in here the drug user
becomes I'm sorry I'm just losing a bit
of control here I'll be with you in a
second this went the wrong direction
yeah at that point the drug misuse it
becomes drug addicted and there is a
compulsive often overwhelming
involuntary aspect to continuing drug
use and to relapse after a period of
abstinence
so this is clearly arguing that the
there's a transition from goal directed
of voluntary behave
to traumatic we would argue habit based
behaviors do we see this in animals well
we can measure compulsive behavior if we
introduce punishments for drug taking so
for example if the rat is given a mild
electric shock for continuing to
self-administer cocaine will they
continue to do so
normal rats will not let shown with this
little green histogram here
however the hand pulse of rats I
mentioned earlier generally continue to
respond you can see this huge effect
here they continue to respond even in
the face and receive in the air first
consequence of electric shock so
although it's quite a small proportion
of normal rats
it's those rats who develop compulsive
tendencies they're enormous individual
differences here and that's true will
serve stimulant abusers as humans it's
been estimated only about 17 percent of
cocaine abusers actually become cocaine
addicts okay so a hypothesis that by
effort and I have suggested is this link
between impulsivity mediated by the
nucleus accumbens or the ventral
striatum that you see here turns into
with progressive drug use habit based
behaviors involving the progressive
involvement of the dorsal stratum and
also this leads to relapse
susceptibility as you see here so the
neural basis of this is almost certainly
this wiring diagram shown here of the
basal ganglia this has been illuminated
beautifully by Suzanne Hebert
so what she's shown is that there's a
cascade of circuits going from the
nucleus accumbens back to the source of
the dopamine system and thence after the
next area of the stratum before coming
back to the next controlling dopamine
system which projects to the
next-in-line
part of the stratum and so on until you
reach
the putamen of the straighten now the
interesting point here is that the
putamen has been linked to habit based
behaviors stimulus-response learning
where the goal is no longer as important
as the skill of the action now how could
we provide some evidence for this well
this is a habit based behavior of rats
responding a lot on a lever to produce
cocaine infusions occasionally as you
see here after 15 minutes the behavior
is held together by these stimulus
response connections if you like which
occur if we tend responses during the
interval if the stimuli the yellow light
you see in this diagram is not present
then the behavior collapses now it's
been shown by a my colleague barry
everett that and luke van der shirin
that if you block the dopamine receptors
in this dorsal straighter region you get
a dose-dependent reduction of self
administration of cocaine suggesting
that the control of the behavior has
been devolved now to this dorsal Strait
or structure by contrast the nucleus
accumbens is no longer important
dopamine locate there does not block the
goal seeking behavior so the idea
therefore is that the control over this
behavior is devolved from the ventral
stratum nucleus accumbens to the dorsal
stratum and that's why it's susceptible
only after a lot of training to dopamine
receptor blockade there now we come back
to this theoretical scheme that drug
addiction really is an example of
instrumental conditioning and what I
mean by that is action consequence
learning or action outcome learning so
this means simply is that if you perform
a particular response in a particular
environment and that leads to a goal
such as a reward
what we call a reinforcer in the form of
a drug or even a drug related cue the
stimulus predicting the drug this all
represents goal directed behavior
whether you've got control over the
environment your response is producing
an outcome and this we think represents
drug use and this and misuse abuse but
habit learning occurs with incredible
repetition gradually the stimulus
response contingency takes over and the
reward is no longer as important so the
drug abuser is performing the behaviors
but the drug summer is no longer as
important as it used to be the behavior
itself has become an end in its own
right if you like and this point we
suggest the habit is a building block
for more compulsive forms of behavior
now we know not about the neural basis
of these two systems the goal-directed
system and the habit system and guess
what they're in parallel circuits in the
basal in the basal ganglia so this
circuit has been shown with food-related
behaviors in humans to consist of the
caudate nucleus here this is an fMRI
study brain activation study the caudate
nucleus and that part of the
orbitofrontal cortex in the middle
between the eyes that you see here
that's the goal-directed system the
habit learning system however is
mediated by this circuit now do we test
don't directed versus habit learning the
way we do that is we devalue the goal so
for rats and humans we just give them
lots of the flavor in advance so that
it's no longer as exciting as it used to
be or maybe we poison the food a bit
make the rattled little something like
that and then see whether the animal of
the human continues to respond for this
devalued goal now if it's a habit they
should because the behaviors become
automatic but
it's still goal directed they should
stop responding because the goal has
been devalued that's the way the logic
works okay so let's see if we can apply
some of these tests to impulsivity but
more especially compulsivity habits as
the basis of compulsive behavior so
first of all OCD so here's some examples
of OCD quite dramatic ones this is
holding I joked that this sometimes
represents fellows at Cambridge their
offices but that's not really true
also at Cambridge we're very particular
about having low-cut graphs and you can
see this perfectionism that's another
aspect of OCD hand washing because of
contempt contamination fears is another
really important symptom of OCD and even
even famous people complain about seat a
for example here Beck's
but many other cases I could mention and
these are those severe symptoms in some
cases they may prevent someone from
actually working or even going down at
their house during the day because they
get caught up with their rituals which
they perform for hours and hours and
hours often they say to relieve anxiety
but we have a view on that
ok well there are interesting
connections between student drug abuse
stimulant drug addiction and OCD and
here's a study which seems to show that
in this study we used what's called
resting state magnetic resonance imaging
with connectivity measures to look at
the wiring of 50 different areas in the
cortex of the human brain so here you
can see two red areas highlighted on the
left hand side these areas turn out to
be in the resting state particularly
disconnected both in OCD and also in
stimulant drug abuse these two areas
intriguing that it's the same two areas
in these two very different or
apparently different conditions
and you can see on the right the
quantification of this the reduced
connectivity of these areas with other
areas of the cortex that's interesting
what's even more interesting is if you
measure compulsivity with a drug scale
called op dose or an
obsessive-compulsive scale called
white-box this khat disconnect ility
correlates with the degree of compulsive
behavior either for drugs which often
means doing drugs rather than
necessarily like in drugs and also for
OCD the level of obsessive-compulsive
symptoms in both cases there's a
relationship between the disconnect
ility of the frontal lobes and the
propensity to perform these compulsive
behaviors that gives me some optimism
that we're dealing with a similar kind
of thing there is something called
compulsivity which affects both groups
there are further evidence that they're
related here's some more work from Karin
OSHA sharing if you look at the central
panel that compulsive disorders
obsessive-compulsive behaviors are quite
prevalent in similar drug abuse and also
as you see here in their siblings
compared to controls and also
recreational drug users very interesting
recreational drug users tend to be
sensation seekers but the siblings of
compulsive drug users do not tend to be
sensation seekers so we think these are
very different risks if you like for
drug abuse and on the left hand side
here you see the base you saw earlier
showing the link perhaps between
impulsivity and compulsivity in the
student abusers and also in their
siblings okay OCD in habits can we test
whether they have more habits are normal
so hypothesis has been that OCD patients
have a disrupted balance between habit
low
in what to do in the context of a
particular stimulus and goal-directed
behaviors learning about consequences
learning that if I do this then that
will happen and our hypothesis is that
this bias to a bitch'll behavior may
underlie their drive to perform
compulsions and OCD is a kind of
behavioral addiction as a consequence of
that now maybe this bias is enhanced by
stress and anxiety and that's why the
habit based systems become compulsive in
their performance but that's something
we'll address in future research having
address the issue of the balance comes
from three tests of habit learning for
humans that we've used we've used one
test of aversive habit learning which is
obviously very relevant in OCD but I
won't have time to talk about it this
afternoon we've used another test of
habit learning versus goal directed
learning which is an ingenious test
based on kind of fruit machines looking
at the balance between what's called
goal directed behavior model based
behavior and model free learning which
is sometimes represented as habit
learning so we've we've done that but
again I don't have time to describe that
I'm going to focus on the fabulous fruit
game so the fabulous fruit game is a
human learning task where you can study
the balance between goal directed
behavior and habits and you can do this
by devaluing the goals or the rewards
that are obtained in the task how is
this done well in this task what happens
is you have to learn the association
between a stimulus on a box which is in
the form of a fruit and a button left or
right button and then in which button to
press in the presence of that fruit to
earn a reward which may be another fruit
which earns you points so let me
describe this a little more detail
here's the stimulus it's bananas you've
got to decide whether to press the left
or the right button
the outcome is a cherry which would only
points if you get it right and what
we've found is that if you have to learn
a whole lot of these associations
patients with OCD and healthy volunteers
are just the same as 111 they show
normal learning however the differences
come when you devalue the rewards now
how do you do this we just simply tell
the subject that bananas are no longer
valuable they don't only points where as
cherries are still good for example and
grapes as you see here are devalued and
then you give them a test you show them
the stimuli on the outside of the boxes
which of course are linked to these
rewards and the subject has to decide
whether to respond to the stimuli or not
now if they respond automatically to the
stimuli it's going to be a habit and we
call this a slip of action as you see
here this is a test of habit learning
and the more slips you make the more
habit downs you are and this is the case
for OCD patients as you see here in blue
so there are more prone to make slips of
action they are more prone to show
evidence of automatic stimulus response
habit learning irrespective of the
devalued guard by contrast and then
intriguingly I should say this
correlates with their symptoms quite
highly doesn't correlate their anxiety
or depression that correlates quite
remarkably highly with their symptoms so
this lab test is telling us something
perhaps about their symptoms now the
other side of the coin is can then
remember the consequences of their
actions can they remember which button
to press to get the reward left or right
and here you see that they're less good
at that
intriguingly they show impaired action
outcome learning so improved habits
impaired actually outcome balance shifts
towards habit learning
and moreover if they're quizzed on the
association's just for the questionnaire
where they have to simply ring things in
order to say which is the right response
forgetting which fruit reward they're
also very bad at that and you can see
that here they're very bad that
subjectively remembering that
consequences of their actions they are
more habit prone they're more biased
habits and we see this for aversive as
well as appetitive habits so we think
therefore the habits may be a building
block of their compulsive behaviors now
what about addiction can we show that
this is relevant for addiction well
there is evidence from some of the Witte
who invented this task she's in
Amsterdam that if you look in the brains
even of normal subjects
there's correlations between white Mets
are connecting the putamen of the basal
ganglia here with the motor cortex and
the slips of action test well there's
there's an opposite relationship for the
goal-directed system and the slips of
action test so in other words it's
possible to see visually the strength of
the connectivity in the brain associated
with the proneness to habits and
possibly therefore the proneness to
compulsive behavior now we haven't
applied this directly to drug abusers
yet but we've in collaboration with
Sanna the weights and others we've used
a similar task of the fabulous fruit
games together habit learning it now
colleagues and this in this study by
stewards and others which I was
fortunate enough to collaborate on we
adapted the fabulous fruit game in the
following way on the left hand side you
can see some of the associations that
people have to learn if one fruit then
this response gives you an apple so the
way you remember the action is that the
froot remind you of the Apple and the
Apple reminds you to press the right
lever that's how you do it
now this task is particularly easy
obviously if the fruits are the same
there's no confusion here whatsoever
if cherries then the right response will
give you cherries and similarly for
oranges but in this special case here
you see a problem if you use the
goal-directed system because we go back
to my game because you can see here that
you can't be confused if strawberry then
pear pear says press right button but in
this case you see the pear again on the
remind you of a strawberry reward which
says press left the pear might confuse
you and say press right actually the
only way to do this task is to use the
habit system and to learn a simple rule
which I show here if strawberry press
right if pear press left
don't try and remember the consequences
of the actions just do the habits that's
the only way to do that task now taking
advantage of that we looked at a group
of alcoholic patients here is the study
involved and we showed that there were
intriguing differences between healthy
volunteers and this group of alcohol
dependent subjects first of all the
healthy controls had increased activity
in these tests in the goal-directed
system in the caudate nucleus you can
see here and also in the orbitofrontal
cortex rather ventral medial area there
so the goal-directed system is working
less well in the alcoholic dependent
group by contrast and this is the
interest in finding the putamen here
it's more active in the incongruent
tasks in the alcoholic disordered group
much more so than the healthy controls
so in essence this suggests that their
habit system is more active in this task
and they're making more use in it so
that's indirect evidence that the
alcoholic abusers prefer to use the
habit system there may be it was always
that way and their relatives showed the
same effect we haven't tested that yet
maybe the alcohol has helped to induce
this drift to the habit system
maybe anxiety or stress has made them
more dependent on this system but
whatever it is the habit system may
contribute certainly to their
drug-seeking compulsive behaviors ok so
I'd like to wind up now finally and
discuss health these ideas work in the
context of the brain here you see a
schematic of the same brain circuits who
have been talking about these are the
different loops they're representing in
this case however horizontally rather
than in parallel longitudinally so I
started off by talking about an
impulsive waiting circuit in yellow
which involves the nucleus accumbens
this structure here and certain areas of
the frontal cortex I also talked about a
stopping circuit which is in parallel
which involve the caudate nucleus and
structures in the frontal lobe in humans
the inferior frontal cortex so these
systems very importantly control
impulsivity by contrast these other
systems going down the slide are more
involved in compulsive behavior so
whereas this is all to do with
anticipation of reward this is all to do
with what happens after the end of a
response sequence when reward has been
delivered now there is evidence which I
hadn't described that this system is
very much involved in flexibility of
goals it certainly involved as I showed
you in goal directed behavior
unfortunately we are out of time I want
to thank the audience for their interest
for participating in today's event and
our speaker dr. Trevor Robbins for his
informative presentation today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
for several months following you'll
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to for that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye